I've lied stolen and taken advantage of
everything to get laid I'm a sex addict
and it's ruining my life I'm a sex
addict I fantasize about strangers
taking advantage of me in random public
places being a sex addict and being in a
relationship is a hard combo on the day
she doesn't want to have any I hate that
I'm a sex addict I feel that I'll never
have a real relationship because of it
I wish guys would stop considering my
sex addiction a turn-on being a sex
addict is not easy everyone's always
judging I'm tired of being that creepy
guy no one wants to talk to I'm addicted
to sex but I'm finding myself needing
more and more to have an orgasm my sex
addiction has changed me as a person I
can't control the urges and find myself
distracted by every beautiful woman that
I see I don't gawk but I can't help to
admire their beauty and body I'm a sex
addict and I don't like being told no
I'm okay until my boyfriend doesn't want
me anymore
but then I cry from rejection I'm a sex
addict and it's annoying because it
ruins my relationship with girls even
though I don't cheat no one knows that
I'm addicted to porn and I was diagnosed
as a sex addict I pretty much hide porn
anywhere I can I feel like I'm a
prisoner in my own body been a month
without sex and I'm literally shaking
feeling withdrawals and struggling to
keep moving forward I live in fear of
commitment because of my sex addiction I
don't want to hurt anyone I masturbate
too much every day multiple times a day
sometimes in public or the bathroom at
work I'm literally addicted to sex in
all forms I am a diagnosed sex addict
most people feel like it's not a big
deal or a real condition if only people
could understand the hell it causes in
my life
[Music]